nalelo simani is one of dozens of
candidates vying for a parliamentary
seat in istini formerly Swaziland
political parties have been banned for
decades in the small Southern African
Kingdom the last absolute monarchy on
the continent I can say I can safely say
we are not allowed to be free we don't
have free speech we are not allowed
because if you speak the truth then you
you find yourself in Exile you find
yourself in chain
King msati III has ruled istini for 37
years protesters accuse him of living
lavishly while ignoring the poverty in
the country of 1.2 million people in May
2021 thousands of people demonstrated
peacefully calling for democratic reform
Security Forces responded swiftly and
observers accused them of
heavy-handedness in cracking down on the
protesters Amnesty International says
more than 80 people were killed and more
than 1,000 arrested in a matter of
months despite a ban on Gatherings and
petitions and an internet blackout
sporadic protest continued last year
close to 600,000 voters are eligible to
choose 59 members of parliament the king
will appoint another 10 most opposition
calling for a boycott and want the
king's Powers diluted but some are
urging voters to go to the polls saying
it's the only way to be heard previously
kingham suti has promised more dialogue
with opposition parties but little has
changed the government says these
elections do represent the people
several Observer groups including one
from the southern African development
Community are expected to monitor the
vote results are expected over the
weekend fam M aljazera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer